ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo video
visto che il video indovinalo con
le emoji vi era piaciuto un sacco ho
deciso di fare la seconda parte ho
trovato la versione delle cards che
avevo utilizzato per l'altro video music
edition quindi con tutti i nomi di
cantanti i titoli delle canzoni da
indovinare proprio come l'altra volta
però non posso giocare da sola cioè
sarebbe una challenge un pò triste
quindi l'altra volta c'è stato edo oggi
c'è edo  in esclusiva per la
prima volta sul mio canale queste qui
dentro questa scatola che adesso aprirò
con molta nonchalance
ci sono delle card delle carte con un
riquadro giallo davanti con delle emoji
che sono le emoji insomma che dovrebbero
farci intuire il titolo esatto
descrivere il titolo il gruppo musicale
eccetera eccetera dietro nel riquadro
rosso c'è il titolo la risposta esatta
la cosa più importante però è che
coinvolgeremo anche voi perché telefoni
alla mano
avremo a disposizione tre aiuti a testa
praticamente posteremo la carta nelle
storie e cercheremo di farci aiutare dai
nostri follower perché magari quella
risposta non la sappiamo e quindi
ovviamente abbiamo bisogno di voi
metteremo dalla parte di ognuno di noi
quelle che indoviniamo così alla fine
poi le conteremo e vedremo chi sarà il
vincitore sperando che ci sia questa
volta c'è questa volta é stato un puro
caso il pareggio
red hot chili peppers yas adoro apro chiudo aspetta baby one more time
questa era per te my loneliness is killing me bellissima posso vederla
anche questo non è un rebus all my single ladies uo o o uo o o
perché sto chiudendo gli occhi
non loro mescoliamo ad occhi chiusi c'é un pó di confusione nei ruoli
non la indovinerai mai perfetto hotel
america hotel california come hai fatto a indovinare
non lo so me lo ricordavo è una
canzone si ok gli é andata di
culo palesemente ragazzi forse questa
non la indovinerai mai tieni gli occhi
chiusi surfin' USA brava surfin' USA yass
comunque siamo sempre pari ragazzi non
va bene questa cosa
ci puoi arrivare oddio catena inbox
montagna ti ricordo che hai tre aiuti a
disposizione abbiamo tre aiuti a
disposizione quindi è arrivato il
momento di chiedere ai tuoi followers chiediamo aiuto ai followers edo ha
appena postato la storia quindi la
mettiamo qui in standby e andiamo avanti
bye bye Miss American Pie drove my Chevy to the levee but the levee was dry
che cosa sono sempre tutte ste robe è
facile facile sweet dreams
oppure are made of this sweet dreams
of rhythm and dancing bella adoro fammela vedere bellissima pronta
rainbow somewhere over the rainbow questa io l'avrei indovinata
l'ho cantata due giorni fa alla sfilata di
tezenis stai scherzando che mi hai fatto
la storia mentre ballavo black and
yellow black and yellow black and yellow
black and yellow io non la conosco ah no
aspetta aspetta certo che la
conosco super la conosco tanto candyman no è una canzone no
scissor sister wake up in the morning na na na na na na a me vuole insegnare eh vedi la forbice no se lo chiedo ai miei follower
la indovinano si secondo me si vai allora la chiediamo ai maryners
anni 2000 questa cosa inviato vediamo
se i maryners batteranno i quaranters mettilo lí senza farlo vedere ok questo è
senza guardare qua le mettiamo qua
facilissima green days green day green
day green day è sbagliato
green day senza la s cioè vabbè perché
sono buona facile guardo facilissima
radio e massaggio cos'é un gruppo
musicale si ma il massaggio ma non è un
massaggio mari relax ma no radiohead
yas dopo 10 tentativi io non la sapevo red red wine come
facevi a saperla é un rebus facilissimo
ma allora l'aveva letta cento per cento
si era anche facilissimo black and yellow
edoardo qua gatta ci cova te la do ma
secondo me l'avevi vista guardo facile facile cupertino é un indizio
no per niente penny street dai ma che
stronzo way highway cioè ti do un aiuto poi basta
ti ho fatto passare red red wine guarda red così va bene vai pen cos'é la
strada cioè se tu la vedi direction
cos'è la strada se tu la vedi strada
autostrada statale Pennsylvania pem pem
che canzone inizia con pen
penny way of life questa cosa non dovrebbe essere legale dimmene un'altra
sbagliata e te l'annullo
ok non la so era penny lane quella dei
beatles sono una cretina però dai non era
immediato scusami era street pen line
ma non era per line
allora io direi controlliamo un attimo
se i nostri follower hanno indovinato le
risposte allora mi dicono lollipop ma
non è un gruppo internazionale quindi
non credo sweet ariana grande non credo
little mix che le ragazze che ballano
il tango più una caramella
direi di no ecco le sugababes era round round baby round round indovinato invece io vado sul sicuro perché mi
hanno detto per forza sempre andrea che
aveva indovinato anche l'altra volta
il mio aiuto da casa dice linkin park e io non
posso che confermare perché sono un
cretino link in park certo
guarda ci devi pure pensare peperoncino
red
no pepperoni spicy mm spicy twins é la
tua risposta definitiva non la so
dopo questa ti defollowo non siamo più
amici non ci vedremo mai più perché la
risposta era spice girls noooo
sì sì sei rinnegato per sempre dai miei
amici frustami cos é questo mmm vediamo take me on a trip I'd like to go someday take me to NY I'd love to see L.A
adoro adoro questa non la puoi non indovinare up town uptown uptown girl
stiamo ripercorrendo i migliori anni della
nostra vita
questa é carina vediamo é difficilissima dai dammi un aiuto
questo che simbolo é non lo sai neanche tu Korea non è non è un rebus
ah ok koglass kosun non è un rebus ah ok
ti posso dire che è il posto d'origine di
questa canzone gangnam style adoro adoro non la indovini secondo me
però guarda fire flow ring no cos é fire  flow ring non lo so falla su instagram
la indovinano subito è facile ma non è il tuo mood
non è il tuo genere questo sospetto
nei miei confronti beh giustificato direi
cioè dai ma a te tutte quelle piú facili a te quelle che bari vediamo can't read my can't read my
no he can't read my poker face
prego c'é qualcosa con party
manca una parola party
rock music é la tua risposta definitiva
party rock sound party
rock anthem edoardo questa l'hai letta era difficile questo titolo era quella canzone
è party rock anthem si ma le hai lette ma come faccio a leggerle tutte dalle note
musicali come ti fa a venire anthem
perché mi ricordavo la canzone cioè mi
ricordavo il titolo guarda edoardo io non ho parole bella questa mi piace particolarmente
vediamo party party yo
questa è una parola la sai ma la sai ti
ho aiutato un sacco aiutami american
party party states non puoi non averla
mai sentita dal lanciala altrimenti eh dai esatto
secondo aiuto per maryna terzo secondo
prego fire baby fire no é la tua risposta definitiva no
é sbagliata era burn baby burn bene adesso voglio vedere adesso
bisogna diventare più cattivi perché si avvicina la fine
chain smokers agguerriti agguerriti
cavolo prego diamonds
dai salla the eye of the tiger prego a proposito di top
dai ma é difficile non la indovinerai mai mai top of the pops come
fai a saperla l'hai letta in trasparenza sei una merda l'hai letta
in trasparenza non ho parole guarda
veramente che bella era una delle mie preferite una volta
dai é difficile é famosa cosa é famigerata non famosa io la chiedo ai maryners cioè questa non indovina
questa questa infatti vediamo anche a me
party in the usa era la mia brava giusto
grandi maryners avete indovinato questa qui e mi avete regalato un punto scelgo io
vabbè grazie no edoardo questo non vale
scusami eh ma dai non vale adesso le giriamo
la testa le giriamo così cioè scusami
non guardiamo non guardiamo ha
guardato giriamo la testa di la dai
facciamolo insieme vai eh no io devo indovinare la tua e tu devi indovinare la mia
certo certo scissors sisters
cavolo vai dancing queen aspetta zio
mancano queste la mia e la tua questa
qua la tua ancora la devono indovinare
e questa è la mia che ancora la devono
indovinare quindi vediamo
we found love in a hopeless place i maryners sono top
vi ringrazio perché mi avete regalato tre punti raga grazie e io
vediamo edoardo hai a disposizione
due minuti dopodiché basta perché c'é
troppo aiutato troppo aiutato l'ultimo
check vuoi saperlo tempo scaduto non è vero
hotline bling porca non si possono dire
parolacce nei video di maryna facciamo un saluto
a drake un saluto a drake e agli amici di
edoardo che hanno cannato tutti momento
della verità momento del conteggio
l'altra volta avevamo pareggiato con un
18- 18 bellissimo perché lui era convinto
di aver vinto io ero convinta di aver
vinto in realtà avevamo pareggiato vai per
il conteggio 3..2..1 16 -18 seeeee
io comunque sempre 18 edoardo ha perso per poco noi siamo sportivi quindi è
arrivato secondo ci hai provato dai
come ci incoroniamo questa volta io
aspettate qua allora incoronazione
ufficiale prego proprio come fa miss italia
grazie grazie mille per me questa vittoria
è importantissiao perché ero rimasta
molto delusa dal pareggio ma sono molto
sportiva e quindi regalo questa
fantastica corona di fiori hawaiana al
mio avversario e visto che gli voglio
tanto bene anche un microfono da
portarsi a casa per fare delle prove per
migliorare la sua conoscenza musicale
grazie per aver partecipato e ci vediamo
al prossimo video
se non lo avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi
al canale e mettetemi un bel like
commentate e seguitemi su tutti gli
altri social facebook instagram e tiktok
seguite anche edo su instagram
vi lasciamo qua i contatti un bacione ci
vediamo al prossimo video ciao